hey guys Ryan right here hey guys Jerry
here so you [ __ ] homos are gonna
watch the [ __ ] trailer for black mass
[ __ ] [ __ ] of course the mics on
you [ __ ] quit
yeah yeah [ __ ] Boston black mass
trailer - already really want to see
this black mass hey buddy I need you to
listen very carefully to what I'm saying
because there are lessons again and
again throughout your whole life and
[ __ ] you gotta learn from these things
right it's not what you do it's when and
where you do it and who you do it to or
with
[Music]
he's nobody sees it didn't happen to me
oh he's six you really think that's the
best thing to be telling you kid yeah
see still smelling like cheese you can
stop if you try for the devil ism
[Music]
Jimmy when did you get out of Alcatraz
hmm that's nearly 10 years ago well it's
wonderful to have you back in the
neighborhood son
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah yeah that looks good
Alex looks really that's a killer
trailer man I don't know what else to
say
joseline liked the first trailer that
trailer was even better oh my god it
just listen Jerry I don't get my hopes
too high I've been disappointed quite a
few times well I watch a lot of trip
well and trailers are the business of
selling you excitement regardless of
like the whole point of a trail is to
make a movie look good no matter what
you know yeah so it's hard to be
exciting no a lot of times a movie looks
bad and then it is bad but this movie
looks [ __ ] awesome it looks like the
gangster kind of flicks that we'd love
as Americans where the criminal is sort
of perceived as a badass you know like
well yeah it's of a different time you
know this this feels like something you
know that would have come out around the
time like Goodfellas exactly exactly
there's a little bit of slight homage
there in the way shot at least a snipe
that rhythm and that grew in the cool
like rock and roll music yeah [ __ ]
Johnny Depp just looks so that's like
he's an actor I'm praying to God that
it's not just well cut scenes of Johnny
Depp this looks like he's actually doing
it the trailer has sold me that he is
this character at least it may be this
is wrong but like judging by the few
scenes we've seen these trails it looks
like the performance is good now it's
just up to the movie to encase the
performance in good you know editing and
good pacing and good you know well
there's one hell of a cast in this hell
yeah Johnny Depp Benedict Cumberbatch
Adam Scott Adam Scott I met Adam Scott
once at a gas station
hell yeah what was that like did you did
you guys could cast you know no no um he
hit my corner with a golf club it was
really rude it's violent yeah but it's
I'm Scott no what happened was I was
going to the bathroom I come out of the
bathroom and then I see this man like
[ __ ] anxiously waiting to go like
like you got used to tell this guy
really had to take piss I looked up and
I was like holy [ __ ] Sam Scott and then
as he's like rushing past me to get into
the bathroom I was like I really like
your work by the way then he goes thanks
man and then
Chesson are really is like really in a
panic to take a piss I have never seen
an actor of his status be like I really
had to be mad [ __ ] Johnny Depp just
looks so amazing you know I was what I
was watching Donnie Brasco last week
forget about it if you had a bad and and
watching this trailer Mike okay I kind
of hear that that it's in Boston accent
II know there's a little bit of a
similarity there in his voice like
Johnny Depp looks like because he's been
making movies for like his kids lately
you see this and I'm like it looks like
it's gonna be very violent like I kind
of want a red band trailer I kind of
don't as I like it I'll just take the
red band movie when it can yeah like
these two trailers are enough just I'm
just I'm there I'm good like as I was
telling Veronica yesterday how I want to
kind of do like a video that talks about
the necessity or the beauty of violence
and films if handled right like that if
this film has the violence handled right
like it's not like I go all right I
wanted to see some [ __ ] blood and
gore when I go check out a film but if
it supports the character in a certain
way yeah if it has the right amount of
gravity yeah like what it looks like in
this like the violence will probably
[ __ ] violent well yeah it seems to
support who this character was though
you know yeah it's like the trailer is
cool but the violent scenes still look
like huh like yeah yeah he's like
[ __ ] torturing someone at shooting
like it's something that we just haven't
seen I've never seen Johnny Depp just go
all out with guns like that yeah well
it's like you know you have these scenes
where he's talking and he's really
charming and persuasive but you still
feel that sense of danger and in all the
shots where he's like got his foot on
someone's face you can yeah you could
feel the rage in those scenes yes from
these clips they're showing yeah oh
definitely and I was that opening scene
with his kid was awesome yeah it's like
you know he's saying horrible things
yeah that father way is delivery on it
though and uh is what I don't know
that's his wife or something but when
she says you really wanna be saying it's
your kid hey man Guerra is good for
Dakota Johnson man like you know doesn't
go to Johnson yeah not getting I don't
know Heidi oregano I'm getting stuck you
know after I mean like clearly they had
to have shot these pretty close to each
other but like it's nice to see her in a
movie like this after fifty Shades you
50 shades is not necessarily like a
springboard for was like respectful work
you know and I'm glad to see her in
something like this you know should have
been Johnny Depp in Fifty Shades
Christian Grey it would have been
interesting would have been different
I'd like to do you yes yeah much more
you say oh yeah no that's so much like a
suite inside if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow Jerry's playlist
on this channel reasons to Jerry you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get into followers
we can get product placement help us
make a lot more money for less work for
scones I know this looks like an edible
you know what yeah how about this
edibles edibles edible it's an edible
it's just tasty it's an edible Jerry has
just consumed inedible he will get high
I was a little kite in about one hour oh
yeah hi
he talks a lot when he's high he he
shows his erection and sometimes he you
know calls a nun and then apologizes for
her sins it's a really weird process you
know it's how we tame edibles yeah but
edibles will cause you to have a good
time seeing you do all those things
edibles this is an opera